madame la prie madame la présidente mes
chers collègues ma question s'adresse à
monsieur le ministre de la santé nous
avons déjà évoqué dans cet hémicycle
l'éviction des personnels de santé non
vaccinés et souligné la situation
paradoxale de faire revenir dans nos
services hospitaliers des personnels
atteints de covin avec peu de symptômes
mais et en refusant du fait de la
pénurie de personnel en refusant les
personnels ça vacciner cette situation
est encore pire dans les ehpad et je
voudrais revenir également sur le sort
de nos sapeurs pompiers c'est très bien
de pouvoir les remercier et les
féliciter ça serait encore mieux si les
5000 pompiers volontaires que l'on
pourrait réintégrer qui sont non
vaccinés mais qui souhaitent pouvoir
participer aux combats du feu notamment
en gironde et en bretagne surtout que
cette éviction repose sur des faits non
scientifique puisqu'on sait que le
vaccin ne protège pas de la
contamination et nous avons une
couverture vaccinale pas plus de 95% sur
notre sol donc je renouvelle ma question
de cohérence monsieur le ministre
pourquoi perdre tout ce temps pour
réintégrer des personnels administratifs
soignants médico sociaux dans nos ehpad
dans nos hôpitaux et on prenne aux
populations qui souffrent de la canicule
et des incendies merci à vous
[Applaudissements]